Disney Princess are some of the most famous
and beloved movie characters of all time.
Whether we are talking about old Princesses
like Snow White or Sleeping Beauty or ladies
from the new generation like Frozen’s Elsa
of Tangled’s Rapunzel, fans seems to think
they know all there is to know about their
Disney Princesses.
Well, we’re hear to challenge that by bringing
you some mind blowing facts and these famous
animated women.
Enjoy this video and be sure to leave us a
comment below, subscribe to Screen Rant and
click the bell to join the notification team!
Here are 10 Secrets About Disney Princesses
That Will Blow Your Mind
Beauty and The Beast
With more and more footage dropping every
day, the world can’t wait to see the live
action adaption of Beauty and The Beast and
from we’ve seen so far it looks like Emma
Watson will knock the part out of the park.
Belle is definitely one of the most unique
Disney Princesses of all time and she is actually
the one Princess who has hazel eyes.
In her own movie, Belle is the only character
in her town who wears blue and this is to
signify that she is an outsider.
During the conception and creation of Belle
it was also very important that the Princess
would always have a wasp of hair falling in
her face to signify that she is not perfect.
Belle certainly is one of a kind and here’s
hoping Emma Watson does the iconic character
justice!
Frozen
Frozen introduced us to one of the most complex
Disney Princesses of all time in Elsa and
it turns out that the original script actually
had Elsa slotted as the villain of the film.
This apparently changed after the iconic song
“Let It Go” became such a hit amongst
the filmmakers and they decided to turn Elsa
into the empowering Princess we now know and
love.
Elsa was also one of the more complex characters
in terms of animation too as she actually
has 420,000 individual hairs on her head.
To put that in to perspective, Rapunzel AKA
the princess who is famous for her hair, only
has around 27,000 individually animated hairs
on her head.
The Little Mermaid
Other than the fact that it is indeed happening,
we don’t know much about the upcoming live
action adaptation of The Little Mermaid.
One thing is for sure, though, and that is
that the film better feature the iconic song
“Part Of Your World” or there will be
riots.
Interestingly enough, this famous song almost
didn’t make it in to the original animated
film and the story behind this is pretty bizarre.
Apparently, during a test screening of the
underwater film, kids seemed quite bored during
“Part Of Your World” which made Disney
executives question its inclusions.
Luckily, cooler heads prevailed and Walt Disney
Studios decided to keep the ballad in the
movie which we have to say was definitely
a good decision!
Cinderella
One of the most iconic Disney images of all
time is Cinderella’ castle.
It’s in the logo and it’s the centerpiece
of Disney World and all of this is no accident.
Walt Disney actually admitted that Cinderella
was his favorite Disney Princess of all time
and he went even further to say that the scene
where we see Cinderella's dress transformation
was his favorite piece of animation ever.
That’s pretty high praise a character to
receive and it makes sense as Walt famously
said that he identifies with her story and
struggle.
We guess it makes sense why Cinderella was
the first Disney Princess to be given the
live action adaptation in 2015.
The Princess and The Frog
The Princess and The Frog brought a lot of
“firsts” to the world of Disney Princesses
as it introduced the world to the first African
American Princess as well as the first princess
who actually had a job.
Anika Noni Rose did a great job bringing Princess
Tiana to life but did you know that Beyoncé
almost voiced the Princess.
Allegedly, the pop icon didn't think she should
have to audition for the role, which we can
understand, but ultimately this ended up costing
her the part.
We guess that Queen Bee just didn’t want
to stoop down to Princess Bee.
Snow White
Snow White was the first feature length animated
Disney movie and it introduced us to one of
the most famous characters of all time, Snow
White.
The Princess is not only the youngest Disney
Princess of all time but she is also the only
one to actually have her own star on the Walk
Of fame.
Adriana Caselotti, the actress who voiced
Snow White, was only paid $20 a day for the
role.
This sounds criminally low but in 1937 it
was actually a pretty good salary.
80 years later, there have been many different
adaptations and interpretation of the famous
story but when it comes down to it – nothing
compares to the original!
Pocahontas
Although there have been tons of questions
about how historically accurate the events
of Disney’s Pocahontas are, it stills remains
true that she is the only Disney Princess
who was actually a real person.
On top of that Pocahontas also happens to
be one of only two Princesses who have multiple
love interests in their film.
Both Kocoum and John Smith court Pocahontas
in her movie, which causes quite the love
triangle.
The other princess with this distinction is
Frozen's Princess Anna who was famously pursued
by both Prince Hans and Kristoff in her story.
Aladdin
Aladdin is another movie on the long list
of Disney films slated to have live action
adaptation on the way and with characters
this unique we hope they are able to find
the right talent.
Jasmine is a very exciting princess and did
you know that she is actually the only princess
to ever kiss a villain (this became the case
when she kissed Jafar).
Anna, from Frozen, actually came close to
joining Jasmine but her and Hans never actually
kissed – they just sang together!
Another interesting fact about Jasmine is
the fact she and Mulan are the only princesses
to wear pants instead of the traditional Princess
gown.
Mulan
Mulan is undoubtedly the most badass Disney
Princess that we have ever seen and it probably
wouldn’t surprise too many fans to hear
that she is the princess with the highest
body count of all time.
But, did you know that she is actually the
overall Disney character who has taken the
most lives?
Yes, in her original film, Mulan ends up taking
the lives of nearly 4000 Hans and horses,
leaving just six alive.
This is a pretty incredible number of kills
especially when you consider the fact that
Mulan was almost not allowed to fight in the
war at all.
Mulan presents a very empowering female lead
who we do not want to mess with!
Tangled
Tangled is a great movie and the filmmakers
did a great job of staying true to the original
story of Rapunzel while also adding in a ton
of fun new stuff.
All of the detailed animation used for Rapunzel’s
iconic hair was impressive, but there was
another details that fans may have not even
noticed that really showed off how much care
was put into this flic.
Mother Gothel’s dress is specifically designed
to be clearly from the renaissance period
and this is no accident.
Tangled is set in 1780, about 400 years after
the Renaissance, so the presence of the old
dress is actually there to emphasize how long
Gothel had been living.
And with that we have made it to the end of
our list 10 Secrets About Disney Princesses
That Will Blow Your Mind.
Which one of these sneaky facts shocked you
them most?
Who is your favorite Disney Princess of all
time?
Let us know what you think down below in the
comments and be sure to subscribe to Screen
Rant for more fun videos – like this one!